[Music]
well you take the beams obviously have
to select beans that you like the flavor
of so we spend a lot of time in the lab
after that you crack them so this has
been cracked the beans have been cracked
and open and then you can see their
shell and then the center part which is
the meat of the being which is also
called the nib and then after that we
would separate the shell in the nib and
then from there you add other things
basically sugar and sometimes a little
bit extra cocoa butter and vanilla
things like that the ground beans are
for an event with
close off the shell and separates the
mists
from the cell and then from there you
find it and that's what becomes we fall
chocolate liqueur so basically after
after their lab grind the chocolate then
or make a liquor than you need to
temperate in order to
to have a good snap and a good shine
this is sort of what untampered
chocolate looks like you can see the
swirly patterns of the bloom of the
different crystal is starting to grow
the Gold's you want warm so right now
they're in the
go boom that's how
so
I'll bring them all
and vibrated a little bit
with the bubbles out
you
[Music]